>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Okay.
Great. This is the
fifth session of the day
as the board tells me.
This is the intersection of
moral rights and other laws.
As you heard earlier today, the
U.S. adapted the patchwork model
to providing moral rights upon
joining the Berne Convention.
In the U.S. our mechanisms
for recognizing moral
rights come not just
from the Copyright Act itself
but also from a variety
of other federal and state
laws, as well as supplementation
from private ordering.
The patchwork, though, isn't
just the source of moral rights,
it's also the scope
of the rights we have
and that's what we're going
to discuss on this panel.
Not just where those right come
from but how they're defined
and how their definition
is shaped by other laws.
We'll look at the
interactions and instantiations
within the Copyright Act itself
such as the fair use doctrine
and VARA, the boundaries
of VARA,
at free speech considerations
that exist outside of fair use
and the traditional contour of
copyright law, and at business
and contractual arrangements
that guarantee proxies
for moral rights such as you
heard earlier the creative
commons created by license.
We have some amazing panelists
here to discuss these issues.
On my left is professor
Sonya Bonneau
of Georgetown University
Law Center,
to her left is Paul Alan did
we say earlier it was Leevy?
Yeah, not Leavy.
Paul Alan Levy, an attorney
with the Public Citizen
Litigation Group,
to his left is Eugene Mopsik,
a retired professional
photographer
and a longtime advocate
for visual artists,
then Nancy E. Wolf a partner
at the IP media entertainment
law firm Cowan, DeBaets,
and on the far end
is Kate Spelman,
who is here from Seattle
where she's a shareholder
at the law firm Lane Powell.
So I'm going to turn this
over to the panelists
for brief remarks to
discuss various aspects
of these intersections and then
we'll have a number of questions
to discuss among ourselves
and then at the end
as you've seen we'll have
about five minutes hopefully
for audience questions.
So Sonya?
>> Sonya Bonneau: Okay.
Well, I hate to bring up
VARA again but it is one
of the few moral rights
legislative acts that we have
and I just wanted to talk
about an intersection
from a policy standpoint
of VARA's place
in the Copyright Act and its --
the multiplicitous goals that it
-- under which it was enacted.
And even though it's this tiny
tiny narrowly circumscribed
statute, it purported
to do a lot.
A lot of the legislative history
talked about different things.
One was a sense that copyright
law doesn't help the visual
artist who produces
unique objects.
Everyone else works on a system
of number of copies sold whereas
for the visual artist
you sell its over.
The other was what you can think
of as the true moral rights
perspective where it's
about the individual's
connection
with their work although that
to the extent that's what it's
supposed to do there was
really no reason to limit it
to visual artists but
again that's part of it.
You see that in the
there's a lot
of flowery rhetoric romantic
artist type rhetoric whenever
courts talk about it regardless
of whether they are actually
thinking that's important.
And then there was the
cultural preservation side to it
which is what I'm
going to focus on.
As Peter, you discussed earlier,
that is the one the VARA's right
against complete
destruction of a work
of recognized stature is
actually the one aspect of VARA
that is not required by Berne.
So the U.S., despite its
hundred year resistance
to Berne went ahead
and enacted something
that goes a little bit beyond
what was required but not beyond
in a moral rights way.
I think it was part
of their idea
that this could benefit the
public because it assumes
that the artist's interest,
the artist who is enforcing
this right is directly aligned
with the public interest.
So art preservation is good,
we can get moral rights
and we can also serve the public
interest by saving great art.
The problem is within
the Copyright Act,
copyright law is based on
a progress model in which,
as I'm sure you all know, the
author gets a temporary monopoly
on their work so that they
can profit from the number
of copies sold and then that's
the incentive for creativity
and then it goes away and the
public gets access to the work.
Whereas the preservation idea
is a completely different notion
of -- it preserves.
It rewards the status quo and
it's animated by an artist
when someone wants to destroy
their work, and I'm only talking
about the destruction provision.
So you've got a very
different dynamic set up,
and I think that's partly
why it hasn't worked well
and these combinations
and intersections become even
more problematic when you look
at VARA and the fact that
that's the main provision
that is invoked.
I mean very little of it
the case law's attribution
because the circumscribed
set of artifacts
of unique objects is just --
it's limited to that kind of
production and reproduction.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Thank you, Sonya.
[ Laughter ]
Paul do you want to jump in
and talk about free speech?
>> Paul Alan Levy: Sure.
So it's awfully hard to come
out against moral rights;
the catch phrase sounds so good.
And there are certainly
compelling stories told
about abuses directed at works
by certain offbeat
individuals who are authors.
But if moral rights are
legislated they'll be enjoyed
equally by the mainstream
commercial titans.
From a copyleft perspective,
which is mine I worry
about the impact of legislating
new rights on the public domain
and more broadly on
what might be described
as fair uses and
downstream uses.
Because even and even
if the newly adopted moral
rights have fair use exceptions,
you worry about the
transaction costs of having
to defend lawsuits in
which fair use rights
or first amendment rights are
raised as a defense not to speak
of the intimidating
impact of demand letters.
To the extent that the moral
rights debate really represents
a struggle between
individual authors
and what might be called the
corporate copyright exploiting
industries, my sympathies are
certainly with the individuals,
but it's hard to see
moral rights be legislated
that give rights only
against those exploiters.
And moreover it seems to me
that advocates of moral rights
for individual creators
want to have it both ways.
They want to make it
easy to make money
from expression using
the incentives
that copyright law fosters by
licensing works through a system
that facilitates the
use for monetary rewards
and taking advantage of the
ever-increasing remedies
that are available
to copyright owners.
The ridiculous extension
of copyrighted terms
whenever Disney's rights are
about to expire.
The terrifying levels of
statutory damages, advocacy,
criminal enforcement programs
when federal prosecutors
so that rights owners don't have
to have the bother of enforcing
for themselves, and of course
ready awards of attorney fees.
At the same time some creators
want to use moral rights
as a club to stop downstream
uses that they don't
like even though they could have
prevented many of those uses
through licensing making
the kinds of choices
that Melvin talked about but
that most creators don't want
to insert into their
contracts either
because it would make their
works much less marketable
or because they lack
the economic clout
to enforce them or
to insist on them.
So ultimately despite my
sympathies it seems to me
that before we give new rights
to creators we ought to think
about cutting back on the
rights that they already have.
Rather than talking
about moral rights
as a bundle moreover
we ought to be thinking
about specific moral rights.
And it seems to me
the proponents need
to justify the need for
a particular moral right
to the extent -- this goes to
the question that I asked Jane
at the end of her talk.
I mean most of what she
said about the right
to attribution was,
well we agreed to it
and there was a long answer
about why we agreed to it
and we can debate
whether we agreed to
and exactly what we agreed to.
At the very tail end of her
answer we heard something
about the incentive to create
and so what I want to know is:
do we not have sufficient
creation?
Do we need to have more
rights, moral rights in order
to create an incentive
to create?
We also talked about the
interests of consumers
but what evidence is there
that consumers care
about attribution?
Yes, I mean in trademark law the
reason why attribution rights
are important is because in
certain circumstances consumers
care about source.
And when you're in
a circumstance
where the consumers
don't care about source,
you have relatively
little trademark rights.
So what's the evidence that
we need a right of attribution
to serve real interests of
consumers who care about source?
>> Brad A. Greenberg: So Paul
talked about negotiations
and licensing agreements.
That sets up nicely.
Gene, do you want to talk
about how creators
guarantee themselves
at least attribution rights,
sometimes integrity rights,
through guild agreements,
contracts
and how it's maybe a poor fit
for some types of creators?
>> Eugene Mopsik: Well,
I'm going to start out --
I have to make an
observation first,
which is a rather strange irony
that here we are at an event
about authors attribution
and integrity and only one
of the images in the program has
an actual credit for a creator.
We'll go on from there.
And I'm going to make
some general comments
and then I'll actually make
some comments that are on topic.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
To be fair, I think some
of the credits are actually
at the end of the bios.
>> Eugene Mopsik: All right.
It appears to me
that moral right
for all practical purposes
are not on the radar
of visual artists
and photographers.
It's not something that they
think about in negotiations.
They have enough
trouble trying to figure
out whether their work is
published versus unpublished,
and moral rights
just don't exist
for all practical purposes,
and under VARA commercial
artists are excluded
from any real protection.
I would say that VARA and
Berne are both examples
of an analogue solution
to what's now become
a digital problem.
The works that are protected
by VARA are in fact the works
that need the least
amount of protection today
and the commercial works are
much more easily separated
from their identifying
information
than the limited numbers
of works of fine art.
The preservation of
identifying information
such as rights holder,
contact information
and licensing history needs
to be easily associated
and maintained with images.
Ultimately its attribution
is the holy grail
for photographers.
Without that everything really
falls apart, there's no end,
there's no means to get
to creating an ongoing
income stream from works.
While it's trade practice
for editorial work
to customarily have
a creator credit,
the truth of the matter is that
it's very difficult enforce.
And as Alan pointed out, yeah,
the contracts are there but
and the terms are there but
the enforcement is the issue.
And in some cases it's not
enforcement it's just the lack
of having any leverage
in negotiating.
And frequently when
a photographer goes
to a publisher be
it for textbook
or consumer publication, the
contracts that are handed --
they're told take
it or leave it.
This is the contract.
You don't like it, you don't
work, you can go somewhere else.
And unless you happen to be one
of those very rare photographers
like an Annie Leibovitz or,
you know, one of the top
of the food chain,
you're out of luck.
You don't have any leverage.
It's move on and you either
accept those terms or not.
So another example I had a
discussion with Yoko at lunch;
in Getty Images contracts they
generally call for a credit
that reads the photographer's
name, Getty Images.
If you watch CNN or almost
any other television media
and you look for the credit
for images that appear,
it's almost always
simply Getty Images
without the photographer's name.
And why that happens
I, you know,
can be any number of reasons.
It's either it's too
difficult for the station
or they can't follow it or it's
simply that Getty doesn't want
to enforce that portion
of the agreement.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Thanks, Gene.
Nancy, do you want
to jump in there?
>> Nancy E. Wolf: All right.
Well, great.
I'm here today with my hat
for representing a
trade association,
Digital Media Licensing
Association
which is the trade association
of stock for the libraries
and we had Yoko Miyashita
here who is a leading member
so now I don't need
to explain what we do.
That's very helpful.
And it's good to follow
up with Gene, yes.
There's lots of trade practices
and in print editorial you
generally always got the credit,
the photographer name
and then the source
because that's the payment
and that was fairly standard.
You know, digital
revolution has made it
so there's more images being
used ever, yet unfortunately
as even Yoko mentioned
often many of them are just
because someone has
chosen to right click.
And it's interesting because
I do a lot of education
and copyright education
as part of my role
and most people are amazed that
there really is no attribution
and yes, you know, obviously
if we're in the business
of licensing none of
these works are subject
to any kind of moral rights.
So I -- but I think attribution
goes well beyond moral rights
and if you're going
to look at a world
where images can be licensed and
has a future with technology,
it's going to be very important
that there is attribution
and it exists in the form
of a persistent identifier
that can live with
an image and that
that information can
be always attainable.
Metadata, unfortunately,
is not robust.
It gets stripped, half the
software purposely strips it
because the internet
wants to have small files
and that means a lot of
information gets lost.
Orphan works is a bigger
problem with visual images
than anything else because
they're orphaned from birth.
It isn't as if, you know,
that photo libraries
and photographers want the works
out there without information,
it's just that the way
they get published online
that seems to happen.
The industry looked at this
and that for the last probably
since the orphan works act and
probably that was around 2006
or 2008 has started to
consider technology options
which would include image
registries, as Yoko mentioned,
there's already reverse
image search.
But to really make that happen
there needs to be enforcement,
whether it's through what the
Copyright Office could possibly
do through CMI that that
information can stay
with the image and be there.
And even I think if we're
looking at the other laws,
I think because image
licensing had been one to one
and perhaps maybe overwhelming
and seemed to be too difficult
to find ownership that
unfortunately laws
in other areas have broadened.
For example it seems like fair
use particularly with, you know,
art attribution expanded
to make it easier
to use images versus
other works.
And then if you look at
image search which a number
of years ago you'd do an image
search you'd get a little
thumbnail and it would
drive you to the source
so you could actually go
and have an image license.
Now if you look at image search,
you get a beautiful
large display of an image
because the money
in the internet now is
keeping you sticky on a page.
That's where the
advertisers are.
So there's no incentive
to drive you back
to the original creator,
there's, you know,
you can see a small line that
says do you want to just look
at the image or do you
want to see the web site.
Well you have the image,
that's all you need
so you're not driven
back to the web site.
So I think if there was a way
to have persistent identifiers
that stuck and you can then
introduce licensing models
where it would be
easier to license
and maybe you wouldn't have
so much of the overexpansion
of fair use like in Google Books
because it's easier, you know,
not to get permission
and not to have some kind
of licensing mechanism and you
won't have technologies being
built for the narrow
takedown notices.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Great.
Thank you.
Kate?
>> Katherine C. Spelman: My part
in the choir here is the
intersection of moral rights
and real estate,
physical property.
I was a student of VARA,
I thought VARA was
something I understood,
I was also a regular volunteer
at California Lawyers
For the Arts.
And if you can imagine on
a foggy February of 1993,
I alone arrived as
the lawyer volunteer
in a very abandoned
pier warehouse
where we welcomed anyone to come
and ask copyright questions.
And you can imagine that
I was a little terrified
when the door opened
and in walked three giants
really looking pretty rough
with tattoos up their neck and
I had never seen that before,
and I thought the end is near.
But indeed they walked over
and they held up magazines
and travel guides to tell
me that they were indignant
that their murals which they had
carefully painted on Balmy Alley
in San Francisco's Mission
District had been reproduced
without permission and
most of all without payment
to be cover articles and
to be indeed covers of some
of the most famous travel
magazines travel guides
for the city of San Francisco.
And they were indignant
in the sense
that they didn't think it was
fair and I had the pleasure
of telling them that
indeed they were well
within something called the
Visual Artists Rights Act the
VARA and we then began
working together.
I had Scott Turow
had the experience
of his publisher saying, oh
that doesn't apply to you.
I had a very similar
experience in that
when I contacted the
relevant publishers in 1993,
their first answer was what?
What's VARA?
And their second answer was when
I showed them what it was I was
at issue, they said
that's not art.
That's vandalism.
That's not art that's graffiti.
That's not art I don't have
to talk to you, good bye.
And I had to explain
that the people
of Balmy Alley had
made their alley,
the walls of their alley -- and
many of you I'm sure have been
to Balmy Alley and seen how
fantastic these colorful vibrant
magnificent murals are --
that indeed there was consent
and the real estate people
were all in cahoots with this
and we pursued what was several
very very productive settlements
for the community that
had painted these,
painted these excuse me.
Fast forward to 2013 and I get
a call from people in Detroit
who tell me they
have a mural issue
and by now I think I've pretty
much got the rhythm of murals.
I think I've figured
out VARA and murals
and I've got this square dance
and I kind of know the do si do
and I think I'm doing all
right at which point we learn
that what happened -- the
facts are so spectacular I have
to share them with you.
Dan Gilbert, a Cleveland fellow
who owns the Cleveland Cavaliers
and is also revitalizing
Detroit.
He has, you may know, has
brought lots of street artists
to come to Detroit and in one
instance he brought six famous
street artists to come to
Detroit to paint for each
of the parking levels of the
new parking building he had.
He brought fabulous street
artists including Banksy
to Detroit to take a floor
so you'd always remember
where you parked your car.
Well, Banksy finished his
day of work for Dan Gilbert,
who is very generous as a
patron in commissioning this,
and they partied all night
and it ended up that he ended
up in Hamtramck, a little town
inside of the town of Detroit,
and at the Packard, the old
Packard automotive plant
which as many of you know
has been abandoned --
literally abandoned
-- for 26 years.
Abandoned to the point
that no one has paid taxes,
no one has done anything,
it's just no man's land.
And Banksy and his team
stenciled a giant of one
of his favorite stencils
on it and a gallery owner
in Detroit noticed this
happening sent an armed guard
down after Banksy and his team
was done about dawn they sent
down armed guards until a
16 wheeler could be arranged
to come down and they cut the
Banksy stencil out of the wall
of this building, put
it on the 16 wheeler
and then welded a frame around
it, enjoyed for a period of time
and then put it up for sale.
The auction was going
forward, all was going well
until the owner of the
Packard plant thought,
hey that's my plant.
You took my wall.
And so they raised their hands
and said you can't do
that, that's our wall.
And it will amuse you to know
that the judge in the city
and county of Detroit
said, yes it is your wall
and you haven't paid
any taxes for 26 years.
[Laughter] If you would like
standing to bring this dispute
in Detroit you will need to
pay back taxes, penalties
and interest and that comes to X
which was almost three
quarters of a million dollars.
And he quickly said, oh I
guess I don't have a problem.
And the work then was sold at
auction by the gallery company
for about $325,000,
this big piece.
And when Banksy was
contacted he was like,
yeah I had a good time.
I knew what I was
doing, okay by me.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
So, Kate, that --
>> Katherine C. Spelman: So my
intersection is that of an area
of law that you don't think of
colliding with VARA excuse me.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Well, yeah, I know.
So that this is a good way for
us to sort of close the book
on the VARA discussion
at least for our panel.
And that is that VARA
tries to strike a balance
between property
rights and moral rights.
So here we're really talking
about personality right,
property versus personality.
But pretty quickly after VARA
was enacted we had the Helmsley-
Spear case which, of course,
the court says well these
weren't absolute rights
for for creators and
we have to assume
that traditional property
values have been left,
property right values
have been left in place.
And I think of the Five Points
case something similar with this
in recent years, so I'm
wondering the balance
that VARA strikes between
property and personality rights
and who are the winners
with losers in that balance?
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Well, I
would say it's pretty obvious
that real estate wins over
VARA in most situations.
It just seems that no
matter what the courts seem
to favor property owners.
I remember when I was a
baby lawyer and first going
to federal court
I loved this arch
down in New York
this magnificent arch
and no one else seemed
to like it but me.
So it was taken down.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Not recognized --
work of recognized stature.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: It wasn't
a work of recognized stature.
It was fabulous but, yeah, it's
there's so many ways to wiggle
out of VARA and artists
can waive it so it seems
that property owners and
the value of their property
and if it's inconvenient to
have the art in the lobby
or in the front the
property owners win.
>> Katherine C. Spelman: That's
assuming someone owns it.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Yes.
Other than Banksy.
[ Laughter ]
>> Sonya Bonneau: I
just have a quick point
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Absolutely.
>> Sonya Bonneau: Which is
that it's not surprising
because American law is based on
property rights and so you have
that dissonance whereas
attribution
as is has been obvious
throughout the day is a powerful
social norm that most people
do believe is the right thing
to do.
So just as a moving forward
thing I think attribution has a
lot more grounding
at least in our --
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
So good segue.
Jane Ginsburg in
her keynote talked
about maybe attribution should
be in some of these cases sort
of part of the first
factor in fair use.
And that courts are
looking at, you know,
was the work attributed and so
we get to the issue of fair use
and attribution in
appropriation art.
Should Richard Prince have
to credit Cariou somewhere
on that photograph
or photographs?
Can appropriation artists,
can they still do their art
and be expected to attribute
the source of the work?
>> Eugene Mopsik: You would
think that, at the least,
when Richard Prince took
Jim Krantz's Marlboro Man --
one of these iconic
photographs --
and basically performed copy
work on it, enlarged it,
it was then part of a
significant exhibition
at the Whitney, used
on a poster,
I think to advertise
the show at the Whitney,
sold for substantial
amounts of money,
and he makes no identification
at all of the underlying work?
Nothing? I mean not
a handshake, not a --
I've contacted Jim Krantz
because he was a member
of our association
and spoke with him.
He unfortunately he did not
own the rights to the image
because he'd shot
for a tobacco company
who insisted on work for hire.
So he didn't have the
rights to the work
and the tobacco company really
didn't care what Prince did
with it as long as they
spelled Marlboro correctly.
So there was no issue there
so Prince couldn't
bring any action,
I mean Krantz couldn't
bring any action.
But you would think there would
at least be some acknowledgment
of the underlying
work at the minimum.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
I mean that goes
to when Paul was
talking he talked
about how he didn't really see
how this would benefit authors
and I think that raises
a question about whether
or not the moral rights
would be transferrable.
If they're transferrable,
I think you run
into maybe the same
sort of problem we had
with the reversion
rights before the '76 act.
If they're not transferrable
maybe it looks more like the --
but they are waivable so you
don't get the termination value.
But the question there the sort
of by what Gene was saying is
if the owner of the copyright
doesn't have the interest
in making sure the work is
attributed to who did it,
who can step in if
not the artist?
>> Eugene Mopsik: Go ahead.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
You don't care
[ Laughter ]
>> Paul Alan Levy: This
goes to the question
of whose interests are
served by the moral rights?
If they're freely waivable,
then all you're doing you're
not providing any real right
against the people whose
use is based on permission.
You know traditional copyright
exploiting industries,
you're only getting rights
against downstream users
and so then the question is --
is the benefit that's secured
by creating the right worth the
imposition on the later users?
I think you need to -- you
have to make an argument
for why the benefit is needed.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: I
think Nancy has the argument.
>> Paul Alan Levy: What?
>> Nancy E. Wolf: I'm thinking
you're putting it in a category
where there's again winners
and losers and us and them,
but I think the impetus
for moral right it's a personal
right that doesn't attach
to a personal work, but
it's a right of an artist
to always say, you
know, that's my work.
It belongs to me.
I mean I still remember
doing contracts
where an illustrator worked for
like a large animation company
and they were told they
weren't even allowed
to put the work in
their portfolio.
And I said you know you have
a right to say you did that.
But if there was a persistent
attribution, you wouldn't worry
about the downstream users
and that right of the artist
to always feel attached
to say I created it.
That when you -- an artist
creates a piece of work --
and I tried Art Students
League so I know the difference
between what I can
do and my clients.
It's a part of them.
They are so attached.
I mean I have clients it's
almost like they're children.
I had one of the artists
from when Prince did the
Instagram one who contacted me
and his work was shown
on art galleries as well.
So I think if we look at
benefit I think the benefit
to the artist is a benefit
to the public as well.
It isn't that there's a
sharp divide that somehow
if you benefit an artist
you've hurt the public
because we're all artists.
In this community of internet
we're users, we're creators,
we're a little bit of both,
and I think making
those bright lines,
we miss having a dialogue.
>> Paul Alan Levy: I think
that's great but you know
when you create a right that's
enforceable in the courts,
that means you have the
potential for litigation
against an individual who
doesn't have regular contact
with lawyers, for whom if
they have to spend $15,
$20,000 to defend themselves
for something they put
on their Facebook page,
they've already lost.
So if you -- I come back to --
>> Nancy E. Wolf: But most
artists have never gone
to court.
They can't.
The only one who goes
to court is Prince.
He sells his work for
a million dollars.
I mean, what the artists
are really looking
for now is the copyright
small claims court
where something could be
resolved for the actual value
of the license where it
wouldn't be so burdensome.
>> Eugene Mopsik: The
right holders are primarily
disenfranchised right now.
They can't bring $150,
$200,000 federal copyright case.
You know the average
photographer is just unable
to do that.
>> Paul Alan Levy: You're saying
the right holder or the creator?
>> Eugene Mopsik:
Well for me most
of my photographer friends
are still the rights holder.
And the creator.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: So if I
can turn the direction a little
to where contract law seems
to be doing more
work there are well,
there's at least two areas.
One is and we can start with
well, there's the director
who can retain final
cut authority
because they have the bargaining
position or you have the editor
who gets credited because it's
part of the guild agreements.
The question here isn't what
is the source of the right
but how important are
those rights as provided
for by contracts and
guild agreements?
How important are
they to authors?
>> Eugene Mopsik: Well, I mean
I'll speak as creator and author
and not as an advocate
that from my standpoint
and what we you heard
earlier from creators,
I think you know creators
do want to be recognized
for the fruits of their labor
and they want to see their name,
you know, associated with their
good works and it's just part
of the creative process I think.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: I'll speak for
the film lawyers in my office
who I get to do all their fair
use reviews but I can tell you
that credit is significant and
I think as one of those terms
that gets it's importantly
negotiated and where it is
and the placement and
the size it matters
because that's your that's your
career that's your portfolio.
You're going to make your next
movie based on the success
of the one before and again
having the acknowledgment
for the fruit of your labor
is I think a significant moral
attribute but also
financial ends up being.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Yeah.
Let me just say, so I don't know
how many of you watch television
in December, you know at the
end of the year I always seem
to have the TV on
when the Today --
I think it's the Today Show --
they do this year in photos on
the morning and they show 10,
15 of what they say are
the most fabulous images
from the past year.
Invariably those images
have no attribution.
They don't tell you who
the photographer was
who took these fabulous images.
And as my mother would say they
all sit there and kvell and this
and that and what a beautiful
photograph how great it is
and this and that but they don't
tell you who took the picture.
I mean it's incredible.
I mean how hard is that?
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Well, what role then,
to add to that question,
does private ordering
play for these authors?
I mean do they look
at copyright law
and say copyright law doesn't
have an attribution right
but I know I can
get it from contact
or do they just not even think
in terms of copyright law
when it comes to
attribution or placement
and they're really
thinking in terms of deals?
>> Nancy E. Wolf: I think
it's bargaining power and yeah
if you're at a certain level
you can require attribution.
I mean if we were just
talking about photography,
typically if it's something
in advertising it's never
been the norm and you're no,
you know -- even I think Annie
Leibovitz won't get credit
in an ad.
She'll get it for the cover
of a Conde Nast magazine
but not for an ad.
>> Katherine C. Spelman:
I would say it's an
enfranchisement tool.
I would say that particularly
for those who work on murals
that they get it and
they really understand it
and it became a civics class now
in the Mission District
of San Francisco.
It's actually in
their curriculum.
These kids really care about it.
This is, they think it's just,
so they're really
enfranchised because of it.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: So
that's really interesting
because in '96 this Office
did a study looking at VARA
and the first I think
five years of it and one
of the things I remember from
the study was that something
like half of or I think half
of visual artists didn't know
that your right could
be waived --
rights could be waived
and something like a third
or another half had
said that when they --
when they had blanched
at the waiver provision
it killed the whole deal.
Has the climate then
changed for visual artists?
Do they feel like they have
more bargaining power to insist
on certain terms or is it
are we in the same place?
>> Eugene Mopsik: I'd say
they have less leverage now
than they've ever had
in the marketplace
because the publishers
are scrambling
for every dollar they can
get out of the proposition
and the rights package that
photographers have been asked
to sign is significantly
expanded now
because you're asked to
give rights not only --
I mean it used to be 20,
30 years ago, you know,
it was a North American, one
time, first publication prints.
Now it's you know on any
platform now known or envisioned
or what's the term they use?
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Later developed.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Later created.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Later created,
you know it's all
forward thinking and --
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Throughout the universe.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Right,
throughout the universe.
And you've got -- it leaves you,
it leaves the creator
with nothing.
It leaves you with
no ancillary rights.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Kate, is the same true
for muralists and sculptors?
>> Katherine C. Spelman: No.
What I'm seeing is
there's this break here
that seems pretty clear that
those people who are dealing
with photography which is
digital ab initio is it's a much
more volatile problematic area
than what people are doing
when they are as a community
group painting on walls
or as an individual
painting on walls
or perhaps in sculpture as well.
But I'm seeing is schism and
I'm wondering what the other
speakers think about this.
Nancy?
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Well,
I think with sculpture
in fact I was helping a UK
lawyer look at a commission
for a large sculpture agreement
for a real property owner
in Philadelphia and I
was like so surprised.
I didn't see any moral
rights clause or any waiver
because I think a
real estate lawyer did
that contract and had no idea.
I could just tell
the way it's written.
But I think if you're doing
something for a large museum,
they've read all the cases
that deal with moral rights
and they know how to write
contracts that, you know,
protects the interests if
something needs to be moved
or it's not finished or altered.
>> Sonya Bonneau: MASS MoCA did
not have a contract with Buchel.
That was -- that, the
judge was incredulous.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Right.
So I think they've
learned from the MASS MoCA
that museums need
contracts and they learned
that they should ask for waiver
and I think if you don't agree,
you might not get a commission.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: So it's
not just the type of artist
but also the type of contracting
party, where the schisms are.
I think our last question that
I'll ask before we open it
up to the audience is
that we typically think
of these probably because
Berne requires attribution
and integrity rights but
there are other moral rights.
And I think there's an analogue
maybe in the digital age
to the right of withdrawal,
which is something like a right
to opt out or a right
to insist on non-use.
The direction though the
fair use doctrine has moved
and the Google Books
search denial
of cert today I think
really hammers this home
that this is a question
for authors is,
how do I opt out
of these systems?
Does that seem like that should
be part of a moral rights suite?
Is this something
authors are thinking of
or wish could think of?
>> Paul Allen Levy: A
right to be forgotten.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
I don't want to use
that term because it's not.
It's not, right?
This isn't like fully removing
your work from the marketplace
but it's a right to say I
don't want to be part of that
that new distribution system.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Well, I mean
the problem as Yoko pointed out,
you know, a company
like Getty is able
to put certain limitations
on works
and the most common ones have
to do with liquor and smoking.
But beyond that, you know,
once once the work is out there
and the identifying
information is no longer
with it, you have no control.
And that's when I've
listened to people talk
about contracts all day but
yeah contracts are great
but it ultimately it means
you've got to be able
to control the distribution
of the work.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: And
that's a clear threshold problem
but assume that wasn't an issue.
Just assume in a
utopian universe
that you could you always
knew where your work ended up
and you knew if somebody
was using it.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Go ahead.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Yeah.
Well, one thing I see one
sort of bump in the road
which is I think once
something is considered
or would be considered
a fair use,
then it's considered
an authorized use
and I don't know there
there might be a conflict
between the right to have
a work removed particularly
if someone has added a lot
of substantial creativity
to it, to the new work.
I think that might be difficult
if it was the work unaltered,
you know, it's always
going to be cash somewhere.
I think in that way you
can compare it a little bit
to the right to be forgotten.
In Europe where the original
article will never disappear
but the links to it go down.
I think it's very hard
to wipe clean the web.
>> Paul Alan Levy: It's
awfully hard to think
of enforcing anything like
the right to be forgotten
in a country that has
a first amendment.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Uh huh.
>> Paul Alan Levy: And I
think that's the problem
with the right to be withdrawn
to the extent that
it's a fair use.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Yeah.
>> Paul Alan Levy: Or maybe you
don't have a fair use provision
but then you're just going
to be litigating the
first amendment issues
when you're asking a court to
order the removal of something.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Yeah.
I guess we have time for
one last follow up to that.
So Paul just to follow up on
your first amendment discussion,
some of the a lot of the
patchwork comes from outside
of copyright law where the fair
use doctrine doesn't necessarily
or doesn't apply.
What role there does
the first amendment do?
>> Paul Alan Levy:
Well, you're --
certainly in the right
of publicity area you end
up applying the right of fair
use by analogy and to the extent
that you don't have the right
of fair use or even backing
up what there is, the first
amendment has very broad
application in right
of publicity cases certainly
outside the purely commercial
exploitation situations.
But there is a first
amendment right to engage
in commercial speech and
then there's the distinction
between having it in an
advertisement or having it
in a product that's sold, and
yet then you have protection
for what's considered to
be noncommercial speech
in a commercially sold
work like the advertisement
in the New York Times for which
the New York Times was held
not liable.
In New York Times v.
Sullivan, this was treated
as noncommercial speech
even though it was ad,
so the first amendment
has ample role to play
in these sorts of situations.
>> Sonya Bonneau: Although I
think that's why Michael Jordan
was successful and he had
several lawsuits and it --
because commercial speech
gets less protection
under the first amendment.
That's a big question of is
it commercial speech or not
and if courts get into
this classification system
where they have to say
what a given work is.
Is it art, is it advertising?
>> Paul Alan Levy: Right.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Great.
Well I think now we're going
to open it up to the floor
so if you have questions
just give me a little hand
and I can tell Donald or
someone else to bring you a mic.
Yeah, Michael Wolfe
>> Michael Wolfe: Thanks
very much for that.
I greatly enjoyed the panel.
I'm going to preface this by
saying that my organization,
Authors Alliance, is in many
ways is also sympathetic
to copyleft ideas, but
we also endorse the idea
of an attribution right.
But all the same I do find
Paul's earlier point an
important one and I think
Danielle made the point before
him regarding the real source of
attribution controversies being
from downstream licensed
uses, so I wanted to sharpen
that a little bit
for the panel and see
if we can't all address
it and find
out whether there's
something else there.
But is there -- assuming a
waivable right, is there,
is there a practical
value for authors
from a waivable attribution
right
if it's only downstream licensed
uses that is the problem?
And if it's not and
if there's more
than downstream licensed
uses that are the problem,
let's say Richard
Prince for example,
although I think he is the
exception rather than the rule,
where will there
been an instance
of an attribution controversy
that is not also an infringement
of the rights of copyright and
remediable from that avenue?
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Any takers?
>> Paul Alan Levy:
I mean certainly
to the extent particularly when
you're dealing outside the range
of form contracts with a
huge commercial enterprises
with which a creator is
dealing, a writings requirement
and an explicit writings
requirement
at least provides a point
of discussion and sort
of conscious giving
up or conscious taking
and I think requirements of
clear and unmistakable waiver,
for example, play a large
role in many areas of law
and I think they're valuable.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Just
one brief comment.
What you commented on
the difference between
or the ability to remedy through
if something were a copyright
infringement that you
could in fact bring a case.
And I go back to my
earlier comment that by
and large that's not a remedy.
At least not a remedy for
a photographer who makes 30
to $50,000 a year who most
probably didn't register his
work to begin with, there's no
remedy for those myriad of uses
that are being made of his work.
>> Michael Wolfe:
That's a fair point
from a procedural stand point
but would this would the
moral right be more accessible
to the author in that instance?
I suppose there will
be follow-up.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Well, I
guess it depends what you mean
by accessible.
If an individual
author has to try
to locate all these
downstream users,
most of the problem is it's
the impossibility of it.
They could be anywhere
in the world.
How do you go after them?
I think that's been
a lot of the problem
with anything that goes viral.
I mean if you, you
know, take something
so you've made another
copy rather
than do what Getty Images
does and allow you to embed
where you go back to the
source, it's really, you know,
an impossibility to whether
it's under moral rights
or copyright infringement
really to enforce most
of those downstream uses.
>> Eugene Mopsik: And
I'll just say about if
in fact the moral right is
waivable, I would venture
to guess that when it
comes down to a negotiation
with a photographer who's faced
with what I call
the 30 day horizon
which is the next billing cycle
and he's got to pay his bills
and worried about rent
and everything else,
he's going to give
up that right.
No question.
>> Sonya Bonneau: But if the law
gets too complicated then it can
have the chilling
effect on for lack
of a better word amateur users
who are using the web just
like the big commercial players.
And so we have to think
about how accessible the
legislation would be to use.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Yeah, we're
not chasing the amateurs.
>> Jane Ginsburg: If
it's not inappropriate,
I'd like to venture an
answer to the question,
which is one big difference is
between an infringement action
and a moral rights action is
if the authors doesn't have
the economic rights any more,
the author doesn't have
an infringement action
but the author could is still
have a moral rights action.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Good point.
>> Jane Ginsburg: And I'd
like to make another suggestion
regarding downstream uses
which may require
legislation but I have to think
about if you could do it
without legislation which is,
as Nancy says, nobody wants
to go after downstream users.
But what about the platforms?
Could there been a 512 type
claim based on attribution?
So in other words if there's
no attribution on the content
that has been placed
on the platform,
that would be the basis
to either have it taken
down or attribution added.
So that might be a way
of rendering enforceable
and attribution right
which is distinct
from the economic right.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: And if there
were persistent identifiers
that readily identified
the owner of a work,
then maybe the issue of all this
red flag knowledge would raise
its head again.
I mean if you knew what
was getting uploaded
on your platform was
not by the same name
as who was uploading it --
>> Jane Ginsburg: It
would be interesting to --
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Interesting.
>> Jane Ginsburg: To construct
all of this, also I'll point
out however that the,
at least under CMI,
it's the rightsholder.
And again the rightsholder is
not necessarily the author,
so you would have to have a
basis for the author to protect
that robust information.
>> Eugene Mopsik: The
plus system does that.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Yeah,
the plus system is trying
to do that right now.
>> Eugene Mopsik: It recognizes
both the rights holder
and the creator and
licensors, licensees.
>> Jane Ginsburg: Right.
But I mean in addition
to the technical
basis, the legal basis.
>> Eugene Mopsik: Right.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
Mickey, you've got the mic?
>> Mickey Osterriecher: Yeah.
Just we've been talking
about attribution rights
versus economic rights but
what we're seeing especially
with photography is
people see your name
and then they contact you and
say well, we don't have a budget
but we'll give you a credit.
Do want to talk about that
kind of reverse problem?
>> Eugene Mopsik: Yeah, that's,
you know, the attribution
on the one level
helps build the brand
and so it you know helps the
photographer become identified.
At the same time it certainly
doesn't pay the bills directly
and there are as Mickey points
out, numerous cases I had --
I mean many years
ago I did photographs
of the lighted Ben Franklin
bridge in Philadelphia
and the architect calls me
up and he had the opportunity
to license these images
to use for his purposes
and when he found, you know,
I give him the fees for it
and he didn't want to pay.
He didn't want to do anything.
Well, then two years
later I get a call
from AIA they're giving this
man some life achievement award
and they want to use
my photographs as part
of the presentation
thanking him.
And so I said you know
he had the opportunity
to license these images
and he turned it down.
I said what do you
have in your budget
to use this image in
your presentation?
And they said well we
don't have any money
but we'll give you a credit.
And I said to them look I have
to tell you I make my money
through licensing images and
through creating photography
and quite frankly I'm not an
architectural photographer.
I did these images of the bridge
just because it was something
that I happened to like,
so I did them on spec
and then sold them
to a magazine,
and I said that that
credit has no value to me.
I said I'm sorry we can't
eat the portfolio piece.
It doesn't work.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
We've got time
for one more question I think.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> I just wondered, given how
the CMI information is stripped
from images, do we really want
to put an affirmative duty
on fair users to be able
to have, to then find
out who the author is in order
to give them attribution?
>> Paul Alan Levy: Certainly
from a litigation standpoint,
as somebody who represents
individuals I would worry
about that.
Also wondering what are the
remedies for having failed to do
that -- if it's simply
injunctive that's one thing.
If it's damages and attorney
fees it's very different,
and yet if you don't have the
monetary remedies what's the
disincentive to do it?
>> Brad A. Greenberg: You know
if I could ask to follow-up
to just sharpen that question,
what though is the real harm
to a user and if they're going
to use somebody else's photo
or someone else's music
or someone else's whatever
that they either use something
that they know they can
identify the author and credit
that author or they
don't use the work.
Like I guess I don't --
>> Paul Alan Levy: So I'm
putting up a photograph
on my Facebook of course
Facebook requires me to sort
of verify that I've
got the authority,
but I think for the small
user knowing actually how
to stick that stuff in --
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Sure.
Well so we -- but that can
be the reasonableness a
requirement, right?
Similar to with broadcast
where it's not reasonable
to include the attribution
maybe there it's, you know,
for the user who it couldn't
make sense or there's nowhere
to put it or what not.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: There is a
free web site called TinEye
and you can put the
URL with an image in
and it will find
you all the matches.
You may not get the one
that actually is the owner,
but it is really
fast and really easy.
So I think this question now
it might not be reasonable
but I can see a future where
this could be much easier.
>> Sonya Bonneau: There
would also be a question
of how the secondary user
used it and how much of it,
all the questions that come up
in fair use might complicate,
well when is the right
of attribution triggered?
Is it with Blanch v.
Koons, like how much
of that photograph
you know can and so
when can you demand
an attribution right?
Could be complicated with remix.
>> Brad A. Greenberg: Sure.
>> Nancy E. Wolf: Creative
Commons has an attribution right
on almost all their licenses
which are noneconomic.
>> Brad A. Greenberg:
The default used
to be no rights reserved but
they found that, I don't know,
97 percent of people opted
for the credit created by.
Yeah, so I guess on that note
I think we have a ten-minute
break now.
If I'm wrong on that
someone correct me.
But 15 minute break
and then we're back
in here I guess at 3:30.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.